bring up Joe's Sam Adams commercial many
classes that made me cry
can I make you cry healed that made that
almost made it easy early we started
driving on this I'd get it together
that's nice my mom it was nice Joe is
you did it for your mom who actually was
super considerate and enjoyed it and
then when I did for Brian he he didn't
care no I did I did care actually all
the jokes I don't want to miss my dream
come true
that's the view for my house Connick yo
yo yo yo de have you seen this jo koy
stand-up comedian and I'm here to toast
my mother how you gonna make me cry
without her none of this would have
happened now is that your house
frequently coolness could be cool I'm
[ __ ] cool dude that's my pool you're
supposed yeah it's a music you sad you
know dis story that makes me yeah you
[ __ ] thank me but grateful [ __ ] my mom
sacrificed everything to make me the
opportunity to live my dream and this
toast was the best opportunity for me to
say thank you when I get your hazelnuts
my eyes out of my [ __ ] face this is
my favorite commercial game I'm not
kidding are you serious right I got his
40 ours is old and that bad family what
I said I want to be a comic her head was
like what are you crazy
that's your pool yeah I know it looks
like a hotel does that a four-season
feeling yeah yeah this is a great
commercial know we live in a country
where dreams are possible and it can't
happen just gimme some time since day
one I wanted to make sure that the world
could laugh and when I tell your story
on stage it's something that I'm very
proud of for years I was like how am I
gonna talk about my mom I didn't want to
go up on stage and just be like oh I'm
Filipino or full of people's do this no
take the shades off you're gonna be like
oh my mom does the same [ __ ] I mean
you're doing great and then probably you
wanted me to be a lawyer
well we digress now I see being a
comedian my goodness I mean you're 1000%
secure Sam Adams it's grassroots it's
family what I take from that is the same
thing that I got from my mom and that's
why Sam Adams is the best beer for this
toast the reason why I brought here
today is I wanted to toast you this is
hard harder than I thought when you came
to this country it was to give the kids
an opportunity that you knew that you
would never have everywhere I go people
will be yelling your name and they grab
their hand and I know it's because of
you so I also wanted the moment I'm so
proud of you you see you started this
you're the reason why I've been able to
do this thank you for everything you
sacrificed
so this is for you
good I love you dude I came all right
are we doing everybody this far without
dinner
I can't even take it slow down lady you
want some more mommy could have put that
to [ __ ] you is that the purest form of
love between a son and a mother though I
can't believe made that for you I can't
take that commercial man now you just
made me cry
everybody's crying now yeah just life
are the same Adam does say they have an
office all of them good music everything
I'm the man to ask that money Brides
whatever
ours is great but I look so I mean I'm a
treat I thought it was great I love you
up there but I can't watch that either
that makes me emotion but do I know the
show is on the thing we don't do that
enough we narrate you and I never do
that you and I never do that ever were
you taking the time to just like yeah
thanks somebody or if you want me to cry
though but you know if you want me to
cry if I if I've talked about my brother
my dad my mom yeah dude yeah that did
that was hard says like especially cuz
my mom did not want me to be a comic for
so long she just didn't get it
idiot am i right all right but it's like
she's an immigrant mom she comes from a
very hard place but that's up it's what
she wants yeah yeah but we're talking
about someone that came from the
Philippines so it's even harder or don't
pay from and her whole thing was like
I'm gonna have kids but I don't want my
kid to be in the position where I was
when I was his age that's not why I came
to America yeah so for a hint for me to
choose something that you know to her is
just like insane it's insane what are
you doing and then like I don't know
where my son was uh when when I just had
my son he was like eight months old and
she took off all this money and gave it
to me and she was buy a car
your son needs to be in a nice car and
she started crying and I was just like
oh she as I'm working at Nordstrom Rack
chasing my dream to be a [ __ ]
comedian you know me
and I'm just like godlike but I didn't
want to like tell her I'm gonna you know
I didn't want to say I'm gonna quit okay
mom you're right
like I just give me some time it's gonna
happen yeah that's incredible that's
it's incredible understood I said you
know what's interesting now is like
let's say your son wants to be a comic
it's just it's obviously you have a
different perspective because you are
such a successful comic but it's just
like even if he wants to be a comic the
chance of making it's not good no
especially growing up Wednesday was I
went oh boy how was I when you tell me
you wanted to be a comic yeah Brendon
was like I want to be a comic and I was
like this he does you joke about but I
was like oh like my voice got high well
yeah oh wow do you want that's what you
want you know it's like because yeah
time Calvin tells the story about how
when my first set in the belly room how
he sit next you and you're like man he's
so brave but it I mean this is it
you know it's right it's to take him at
least 15 years look I couldn't help but
worry I know I know
no call just because I embody the hold
on so how is this it's about just kung
fu kung fu' yeah you're saying oh well
that's how it's said so as I'm from I
studied in China Poisson